electrifying expensive fast-paced New
York is one of the world's most
important economic centers more than
7,000 high-tech companies are
headquartered here
and many of us are unhappy with
something that a teammate delivers on a
you know they don't do a good job on a
task we're not happy with a product we
simply just put it next to the person
and that's our way basically of saying
that we think what you did is not a very
nice word the New York Polytechnic
school uses these offices for its young
entrepreneurs in their mitts now are
representatives of three German startups
they're developing business concepts for
the US market we are active in the area
of multi-screen advertising we look at
the fact that in most living rooms today
the television is only one of many
screens there are smartphones tablets
laptops around and this is a huge
challenge for the advertiser who
traditionally booked TV advertising in
the hope to reach the consumer we help
them reach them even in today's world by
synchronizing television advertising
with digital advertising we describe
ourselves as a fan powered tour promoter
that means that stage link provides
artists but also their managers and
agents were the tool set for them to
efficiently promote their shows and
tours we help our clients identify
engage and win the best talent for their
organizations and we do that in a way
that we actively support the the process
of selecting talents for them our
clients no longer post and pray as they
say post a position and then hope the
right candidates will apply they
actively go out in the market and seek
the best talent and we have technology
and services that supports them doing
that
tobias schmidt has big plans for his
firm it helps companies reach viewers
with TV advertising on all their devices
he's been successful with that service
in Germany and now he's aiming for the
US market on New York's Times Square he
feels the challenge thousands of screens
are basically fighting for the attention
of the consumer and it's really hard to
find their way to navigate through all
these advertisements that are coming to
the users at noon in Manhattan Teddy
Goldstein meets the German from the
startup stage link Goldstein is a
musician
today he manages what he calls German
accelerator a service for startups from
Germany he helps them make contacts and
organizes things they need
I was a touring musician and actually in
a lot of ways I realized being an
independent artist is like being your
own startup in the sense where you have
to figure out where you're gonna play
who your fans are letting them know
you're coming and before you know you
have a business it's easier to found a
company in New York than in Germany and
failure isn't such a scandal the startup
scene is growing rapidly Stephan
halliche and his colleagues are
preparing to enter the market in the
United States with help from Germany's
federal economic Ministry and from the
German American Chamber of Commerce the
three German startups were chosen in a
competition and have great expectations
intervals in one year will be an
established brand when we go to
conferences like we frequently do these
days people will be oh yeah there's
intervals we know intervals what they're
doing how they're delivering their
services and it's a recognized brands
that will be known for the success that
it has with the customers here in the US
we want to position ourselves much more
internationally so for now we have done
all the events in Germany Austria
Switzerland so far we have some
international artists on the platform
but we just want to expand it and also
have artists here in the US have some
tours here in the years and like
literally this international touring
business that's that where we see our
strengths I guess in a year from now we
want to show ourselves in the market
that we have established a successful
business it must not necessarily be
profitable but fast-growing we must have
signed up numerous customers that we can
say this is a proof of concept and
within the existing customers it is our
aim to increase the share of wallet to
do more business with them
time is short but the infrastructure in
the accelerator helps it's great to have
an office in Manhattan in the heart of
the Big Apple and be in contact with
other new startup companies